hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game six of the World Chess
Championship match between Yani ponachi
and dingler and it just finished and uh
I I I I can't believe how it finished it
is an absolute privilege to show this
game to you and for those of you who
haven't seen the game live I even feel
uh a little bit jealous as you are about
to see uh you are about to see greatness
here it is uh in my opinion the greatest
game that has been played so far uh in
their match and uh well it it could be
one of the greatest that was played in
many other World Series Championship
matches so it's uh reminiscent of every
game six of the world's championship
match it kind of never disappoints I
mean um if you look at any world
championship match game six always
always brings it and I think it all it
also uh sort of uh uh gets to the
players a little bit maybe they feel
pressured uh you know game six is coming
and maybe I play this maybe I play this
maybe I you know uh you sort of feel
obligated to go for something legendary
uh but for some reason it always happens
so that being said let's check out the
game and for a lot of other videos that
I've done on the World Chess
Championship Match you guys uh sometimes
you say okay I just want to see the
moves you're going too deep in the lines
maybe you are over explaining it uh go
in the chapters below at the end of the
video there will be just the moves
section so if you guys want to see just
the moves look at that if you guys want
to check out everything that's happened
because a lot has happened then let's
dive straight into it so here uh ding
has the white pieces and he opens with
Ponte D4 I if you see I've added the at
the points players have accumulated so
far in the imagining has two points uh
nipple has three points and also uh let
me just share this with you the first
move was made by
uh by uh let me just check I I forgot
the name uh yeah I don't have it written
uh so you guys will have to help me out
with this one uh but she made the first
move uh she's the uh head of fide
something I just don't know don't don't
remember what uh so so there we have it
uh and also uh once the opening was
shown and that is Pawn to D4 Knight to
F6 Knight to F3 Pawn to D5 and Bishop to
F for everyone just to win uh completely
mad the London system is on the board
and yes in game six of a world cheers
championship match uh we actually have a
London system and here you can even see
uh yeah Ian had to have a banana right
away as as the game started because uh I
I don't think he was expecting a London
system here uh but as they said it was
um definitely underrater when he was
playing Magnus Carlsen so he probably
did a lot of work how to play against
the London system that being said uh we
have pawned a C5 by yawn very principal
way of dealing with the London just
attacking White Center E3 Knights the C6
and now Knight beta D2 here there are
two main moves for the London C3 and
Knight beta D2 C3 by far the more
popular one ding chooses Knight beta D2
and now it makes sense to attack taking
the center C captures on the four we
have e captures and now Bishop to F5 and
this very nice way of handling the
London usually white wants to play
Bishop to D3 now you just don't allow it
ending plays Pawn to C3 uh basically he
has to decide whether he wants to go
upon the C3 or Bishop to B5 we have E6
by Yan and now Bishop to B5 here ding
took a kind of a longer thing uh
probably Queen to B3 is what he was
thinking about going after B7 but then
he found what probably didn't uh what he
probably didn't have in his preparation
and that is this Pawn sacrifice with
Bishop to D6 and now if Queen captures
and B7 you can just trade here let's the
bishop captures on F4 Queen captures and
C6 with checking effect and you have
this very very uh uneven position where
black has the bishop pair white is up
upon Black's King's side is is
um uh you know you're not going to be
able to Castle but you will play
something like H5 H4 put the Rook on B8
and it's gonna be uh it's gonna be a
very a lovely game so I don't think ding
wanted to play something like this
against Dion uh and in the end he just
decided on Bishop to B5 and okay uh we
have Bishop to D6 Bayonne Dean trades
captures captures and now dangerous
castles and here uh there is a game in
the database I'm talking about classical
games gatakonski played where he won a
very nice game H6 was played against him
I was played by a head insteadminson and
gatakomski defeated him uh the game was
played in in 2015 but here we have
castles Bayan and now uh there are again
a couple of games uh we got gatakamskin
gookish both had these positions with
white and in all of those games Knight
the B3 was played which is kind of a
standard way to play this you want to
put the Knight on B3 and then at some
point the the C5 because once black
plays A6 you know that he's not gonna
play B6 and your knife will be very safe
on C5 so here instead we have Rook the
one by Ding and it is now uh as of move
11 that we have a completely new game
but not really there still are some
online games uh from camskin gookers
that reach this position uh and here uh
we have quanta H6 uh and this is
basically our uh our new move uh of uh
of The Possession uh and okay we have
Knights the E5 and now Knight the E7 the
real question here is what can black do
here because there are very standard
moves that black wants to play here this
is not an unknown position this one is
but Sim similar ones or not so the point
is like I said if you uh in if you try
something like Ponte Asics here then
white can just take and you have to play
B captures and then comes Knight to B3
with the Knight coming to C5 and this
Knight is now a monster there another
thing is that if you're wondering what
about just training here the problem
with trading here is that after captures
okay you don't lose material because you
can play Queen to B6 so you can't play
this but let's say he captures an F6 now
Queen captures and B5 F captures and G7
and it doesn't look like a position you
want to have with black in the World
Chess Championship match so that being
said after Knight A5 we have Knight to
E7 by nipple uh and now Pawn to A4 by
ding uh it's a standard move you want to
play Pawn to B4 and then just go for
that Queen side expansion we have A6 uh
Bishop back to F1 looks like looks like
an odd move to play because you bring
the bishop all the way back but it's uh
for those of you who who have studied
just a little bit know that this is a
very standard way of dealing with your
light Square Bishop being attacked Bobby
Fischer and Magnus Carlson and Paul
morphy won a great games by retreating
their Bishop to F1 and here Knight to D7
this is how Yan wants to oppose the
Knight on E5 but now ding just plays
Knight captures on these seven Queen
captures and now Ponte A5 now
controlling the B6 square and now with
the control over the B6 square and the
control over the E5 Square uh Yan's
counter play is somewhat limited here he
puts the queen on C7 which is a good
Square for the queen in most setups
against the London as white will want to
play B4 at some point you will have
pressure on C3 but also on the A5 Pawn
if Knight comes to C6 the A5 Pawn will
become attacked and here ding goes Queen
to F3 and this is the move that mostly
keeps the tension if you go Knight to B3
right away going for that C5 Square then
Knight the C6 puts pressure on A5 and
now you have to keep defending the pawn
so instead the ding just keeps the
tension Queen to F3 and now Rook F the
C8 Bion it's a weird looking move
because you also want to play Rook 8 to
C8 but uh then if you play Rook 8 to C8
where is The Rook from f8 going to be
developed too uh it's a really uh weird
position B5 might be play later on in
the future so maybe then you want to
have the A6 Pawn protected but you know
from experience that B5 will never be
played like you know you don't allow a
capture some B6 up a song so okay Rook
the A3 by ding now he can play Pawn to
B4 with his C3 Pawn nicely defended uh
and we have Bishop to G6 Bion again just
uh trying not to make any uh positional
uh mistakes putting pieces on optimal
squares here it's really a question
whether the bishop would be better on G6
or on H7 but okay Knight to B3 Now by
Ding and the situation on the clock is
one minute and one hour and 12 minutes
versus one hour and 20 minutes so ding
is actually lower on time even though he
kind of surprised Dion with the
uh with the London system and the Knight
the B3 is basically preparation for
Queen to G3 ding didn't want to play it
right away he's gonna play it now
depending on what Yan plays and Yan does
play Knight to C6 and now ding goes for
it Queen to G3 point being that now if
you trade Queens Queen captures H
captures and let's say Rook the C7 uh
you defend the B7 Pawn because you know
it's gonna be attacked Knight to C5 it's
uh kind of difficult to keep an eye on
things for black let's say rotate the C8
uh you can even imagine some Knight
captures some B7 action happening like
rocatra's Bishop capture Sun A6 and even
though black might not lose this it's
gonna be very hard to play let's say
Rook here captures captures uh and now
the pawns start marching forward this is
not what you want to have in a World
Chess Championship match so after Queen
to G3 we have Queen to E7 uh and now
ding goes for Ponte H4 and it's again a
very nice inclusion uh now Knight the C5
can always be played they knows this and
he he throws in an ice Pawn to H4 and
another thing about Ponto H4 is that
nepo now has the every move calculator
what if ding throws in a nice nice
suspicion Suga H5 after every move that
he plays and okay we have rooked A8 by
nepon and now only now Knight to C5 and
now how do you how do you play this now
there are some very nasty threads here
uh like Knight captures and E6 imagine
if white play if black plays Knight
captures on A5 okay uh hoping that Rook
captures on A5 can be met with B6 but
look at this Rook captures B6 and now
Pawn to H5 that's uh uh why one of the
reasons why didn't play Pawn to H4 and
now after Bishop captures on H5 Knight
captures an E6 threatening Checkmate so
you have to play F captures and now Rook
captures on D5
and the blacks uh position is uh pretty
bad here he has three Pawn Islands D6
Pawn is weak the queen side is weak the
king uh is pretty wide open and not a
lot to be done here you can't even uh
trade um uh two Rooks for a queen
because there's always Queen H4 at the
end of the line so that doesn't work uh
so you're out of any good options here
like Bishop to F7 can be played then you
play Rook here you double up you go
after the weakness and that's pretty
much it so here after Knight the C5 we
have Pawn to E5 by on and this is uh if
young can play E5 it should be good uh
but um it's uh definitely not in this
position because here you Jan did well
what uh usually players need to do when
they play against the London system you
have to wait for whites to be active and
you have to choose your options very
very carefully and I I don't know at
least in my experience when playing
against the London uh in bulletin Blitz
in classical chess I've faced it
everywhere uh it's uh you basically
don't have an active plan depending on
what setup you use of course but uh
that's the the feeling that I got and
here E5 does seem a bit too active and
the ding goes for Rook to B3 another way
to deal with this is Pawn to B4 but of
you guys know that pawn to B4 is a way
to deal with everything and then if E4
which is Black's plan now phone to F3
and you can see that Black's uh Central
upon structure won't really uh hold up
uh so instead after E5 we have Rook to
B3 not just putting pressure on the B7
pawn and now uh Jan goes for it he plays
Knight captures on A5 attacking The Rook
here and defending the B7 Pawn but now
Rook captures on E5 attacks the queen we
have Queen to F6 and now Rook to A3 uh
this is the only move that actually
works for white if you try something
like Queen T3 put pressure on The Rook
here there's always Rook captures and
now if D captures there's Queen to C6 so
this is how you defend and even if you
play Rook to A3 now uh the Knight goes
to C4 okay you can trade here Bishop
capture spawn captures the queen now
guards the B7 Pawn so not not really
great so instead Rook day three going
after the Knight we have Knight the C4
and this is best if you go back Knight
to C6 this is too slow uh Eve uh ding
has to play perfectly here in order to
prove that this is too slow but I will
just show it to you Knight to D7 attacks
the queen and once the queen moves
there's a rook captures Queen characters
and queen to C7 and now if let's say you
trade Queens captures captures the
problem is again Knight C5 and the pawns
are too weak you can play some like Rook
to C7 but Rook to B3 and you can't keep
an eye on on all of them even if Knight
day five you can still play Knights the
B6 uh one of the pawns is going to fall
so instead after Rook day three Knights
the C4 Bayan and now Bishop characters
with d characters and now Ponte H5 uh
here ding could go Knight captures on B7
right away but he gives Yan one chance
he gives him one chance and it's such a
tiny chance that you guys will not
believe this he plays Pawn to H5 Knight
captures on B7 has to be played uh and
then you would have something like Rook
captures Queen captures and yes you lose
the H4 Pawn but not Knights the D6 and
our good friend the engine says black is
completely busted here that those pawns
will not be able to survive once you
pick up this Pawn it's uh basically one
Pawn chain against zero and you will
just push them but the ding plays Spawn
to H5 and he gives nipple for this
incredible opportunity on how nepo could
defend but it's so difficult to find
that for those of you who haven't seen
uh the the the the game will enjoy this
now the move is Rook captures on E5 and
now after d captures look at this your
queen and Bishop are hanging this is
what you have to allow now Queen to d8
and the point is after Dean captures the
bishop you have this queen to D1 check
and now of course you see that it's a
draw King to H2 Queen to H5 check and
now you repeat and there's a repetition
or you go Queen H3 now Queen captures
and if I would check picks up the Knight
and so on or just Queen G3 and then you
repeat Queen to H5 check winter D1 and
so on but the problem is even greater
after Queen to d8 ding is by no means
obligated to capture the bishop he could
also play Queen F3 protect the D1 square
and now it's not so obvious what to do
but again I will show you Queen to D2
and only now after age captures on G6
Queen to E1 check and after King stage 2
Queen captures an E5 with check nicely
connecting with the Knight G3 Queen
captures and C5 and now Queen characters
on F7 uh King the h8 and now Rook day
for going after the C4 Pawn now Rook to
C8 and you get this position with equal
material uh black should be okay but
yeah you have to find all of this and
this is what the things sort of allowed
Jan by playing this Pawn to H5 move but
yeah misses it he played it fairly
quickly he played Bishop to C2 and now
ding goes for it Knight captures on B7
we have Queen to B6 it seems the Knight
is trapped but of course uh it only
seems that way Knights the D6 is played
now if you capture then we'll capture
Sandy E8 with check picks up the queen
and D6 so here Rook captures on E5 we
have Queen captures on E5 it's it's much
better than the characters on E5 uh
because uh here the pawn is passed Pawn
once you capture it's no longer a past
Pawn so Queen captures on E5 with Queen
captures on B2 and now Rook the A5 now
getting the The Rook out of Harm's Way
and now nipple played King the H7 here
still Queen captures in C3 was probably
nipples best uh best optionalistic Queen
captures now Knight d8 threatening
Checkmate uh uh but uh sorry not the
best the the the worst option because
now you have to trade your captors
captures and uh it's a game over so
nipple goes King to H7 uh it is the the
the definitely the way to go and now
Rook the C5 biting here uh ding should
have uh instead of this Rook the C5 went
Queen to E1 uh to just the guard the C3
Pawn now black was threatening to
capture the C3 pawn and now you will
either lose this Pawn or this Pawn
ending will win the game however uh ding
also was alone time he played Rook to C5
but now comes uh uh king a queen to C1
with check here again nipples best bet
was the captain C3 and now after Knight
captures an F7 Bishop D3 and you hold
this you don't have a mate you are
controlling this diagonal you have a
pass Pawn you have the to pass Pawn uh
so this is how you fight but nepo played
Queen to C1 with check we have King the
H2 and now Pawn to F6 he wanted to
defend his F7 Pawn uh but now Queen to
G3 and these are the kind of positions
that uh uh ding thrives in this is uh
things uh things happy Hunting Ground uh
and there's no there's no coming back
from this Yan played A5 he of course
wants to push his pass Pawn to Victory
uh but there is no way of saving this
there is such a spectacular Victory here
that I mean there are so many incredible
positions um in this game that I thought
okay I'm gonna use this for pause the
video I'm going to use this for pause
the video but no I'm gonna use this one
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for ding uh while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh absolute brilliancy and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course Knight captures and C4 it's
always a move with the Knight back so
congratulations to everyone who found
this you are truly a machine at
calculating uh the problem is uh once
you look at The Rook C7 because this
threatens mate you of course find Queen
to G5 and now okay you can go into an
end game let's say characters captures
Knight captures and C4 but now Bishop to
B3 the A2 discover this cover this cover
discover that you can just push the
Knight is being pressured are you really
winning against this past a pawn not
really so that's why Knight captures on
C4 now Ponte a for nipple was probably
expecting Rook to C7 now but no ding
goes further back Knight to E3 he closes
up this diagonal and now Queen to G5 is
no longer a resource for nepo uh and
here Nepal plays Bishop to B1 uh he he
plays Bishop to B1 because he realized
that that fonte A3 is met with the C7
and now Rook the G8 is met with Knight
to D5 going after Knight captures on F6
with check and after King tacha just
rooked A7 and you cannot push a 2d A2
square is covered so that's why uh Nepal
plays Bishop to B1 to cover the A2
Square now he is hoping for that line
but now ding has something else planned
Rook to C7 we have rooked the G8
stopping Checkmate and now ding plays
Knight to D5 with King to h8 and now
Rook the A7 here again Knight the E7 is
um is a very good move but Rook the A7
uh the what ding played is uh uh I mean
just wait till you see it we have Ponte
A3 nepo starts pushing the pass pawn and
now Knights the E7 and here Nepal played
Rook the Fate interestingly uh Rook The
d8 Rook d8 is much much better because
it's so subtle and Rook to E8 might even
Rook date is still lost for Nepal but he
might have certain chances of saving the
game if ding does not play a perfect
game however after this Rook Rook the
Fate move ding's position is just
Spectacular Now ding plays Pawn to D5
and he creates such a spectacular mating
mating web that you guys will not
believe this the problem is uh and I
have to show this one too because if
this was played then you can play Rook
to B7 Rook to B7 is such a spectacular
moving all of these lines because you
prepare Rook to B8 and once Rook to ba
displayed it's game over there's no
defense these are covered by the Knight
the queen covers B8 it's game over
you're gonna Checkmate the black king
the problem is here
I had uh Hyun played this move this
would not be a resource because Jan
would have Queen to beat you that's the
spectacular move here and now it doesn't
matter where you capture the queen or
not you could even play something like
Queen to C7 uh black will capture The
Rook that's the point and after Queen
captures their sponte A2 threatening A1
and now after Queen to A6 there's a rook
captures on E7 grabbing the Knight and
now you definitely have material
compensation for being down a queen
which is very much different uh from
nepo's Rook to f8 move now the Knight is
not attacked and after this um Rook to
V7 move you don't have the resource of
going uh Queen here so Rook the B7 would
be winning by affording but the ding
finds something even prettier he finds
Pawn to D5 uh and now uh how can nipple
play this he plays Pawn to A2 but now
comes Queen to C7 and now I'm sure you
guys uh realize what's going on uh maybe
even nepo didn't realize it because he
was uh kind of bedazzled when uh when if
he came back to the board but he played
King so and of course you have the
sidestep check if if you allow one check
then it's check Bishop captures Knight
and queen captures and G7 will be
Checkmate so here King th7 was played of
course makes sense you you now prevent
check but here uh ding just played
Knight to G6 attacked The Rook uh Rook
the Jade and like I said I'm so jealous
for those of you seeing this for the
first time feel free to pause the video
and try to find the only winning move
for ding while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh uh one of the greatest game six ever
of the world's championship match moves
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course Queen to
F7 uh this is what being played and it
was in this position on move 44 that
Yani ponishu resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here a
ding equalizes the match after game six
the score is now three to three and uh
we go into game seven uh on on equal
terms and the problem is uh here you
resign because it doesn't matter what
you play uh the the threat is too great
uh let's say you play something like A1
Queen now you have uh pretty much
anything you can just capture that Queen
so it doesn't really matter but let's
say you play anything other than that uh
what's the real threat here and what's
the real idea behind the ding playing
Pawn to D5 covering this E6 move let's
say you play uh What uh what move could
you play here let's say play there's
really no good move for black to play
let's play Queen captures and C3 the
real threat is Queen captures and G8
this is what the thing found when he
played that pawn to D5 move and even
though uh if there wasn't Pawn to D5 he
would have found that Bishop to B7 move
but here uh it's just game over and look
at this King captures now comes Rook to
A8 with Chuck King the F7 rooked the f8
and this is now Checkmate and now you
can see that the D5 Pawn covers the E6
square and uh how how amazing is this
how amazing is this that we get such a
game in a worldshire championship match
on game six this is uh the uh this is
almost as if it were scripted this is uh
I mean if if you wanted to make like a
really really uh great movie about about
a chess and World Church championship
this is how you would script it so I I
actually can't believe that we we got
this from a game six over World cheers
championship match but yeah after this
uh Queen to F7 move an apple sober was
going on he looked at Ding and then he
just resigned so absolutely spectacular
stuff ding is back we have a match game
seven unequal terms it's going to be
absolutely spectacular and now as I
promised for those of you who just want
to see the moves of the game without any
explanation uh here are the moves so
here you can see a nice London system uh
just a standard C3 you know uh here we
have it Rook D1 95 there you go okay
Bishop to F1 so this is all nothing
spectacular I think is controlling E5
and A5 players are playing some moves
here uh like I said this is for those of
you who just want to see the position
and the pgns there you have it being
captured upon and B7 then we had this uh
then there there was some action Here
and Now nip started pushing his a pawn
and basically here uh was where the
magic happened linked with D5 created a
mating web Queen to C7 and now look at
this queen to F7 and now a Checkmate is
coming because after let's say something
like this a beautiful uh checkmate with
a queen sacrifice so that was for those
of you who uh would prefer just to see
what happened instead of uh doing the
analysis maybe you don't have time maybe
maybe I'm just you know explaining a bit
too much who knows but there you have it
it's a world just championship match so
a little bit for everyone uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I I myself am thrilled to have been able
to witness this uh it's uh it's like
it's like a you know uh it should be a
like a national holiday or something uh
but yeah as usual uh I I would like to
thank Chris Johnston uh chess salty.com
uh Jacob Gonzalez Adrian Glazer and Alan
drapkin for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World
Chess Championship Match until it
finishes uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day